Speaker 1: e going to continue covering it.
We'll take a break and be back with plenty
more right after this.
Failed.
Former President Donald Trump gave an interview
so bad last night to Fox News propagandist
Sean HANNITY, so depraved, so visibly disoriented
that even Republicans are saying, dude, that
was not good.
We're going to look at the comments of Republicans
in a moment.
But let's first look at what happened in the
interview.
Again, the interview handled by Trump's, I
guess, friend, at least at one point a friend
to the extent Trump has friends.
Fox News propagandist Sean HANNITY and Trump
spent much of the interview equivocating about
the threat of violence against Manhattan.
Da Alvin bragged that he posted a few days
ago and attacking Ron DeSantis.
Neither of which played particularly well
with anybody here.
Sean HANNITY asks Trump about that death and
destruction post, and then the other one showing
him holding a bat next to Alvin Bragg.
And Trump kind of plays dumb, but his explanation
is also completely unintelligible.
Speaker 4: So all this information that came
out in your favor, you talked about death
and destruction and then the baseball bat
picture next to Alvin bragging you did take
that down.
And my only question, why open yourself up
to criticism?
Speaker 3: You have to understand that when
the story was put up, I put up a story.
We didn't see pictures.
We put up a story that was very exculpatory,
very good story from the standpoint of what
we're talking about, what And they put up
a picture of me and, you know, where I was
holding the baseball bat.
It was at the White House, Make America Buy
America, because they did a lot of buy America
things.
Speaker 1: So I guess he's saying because
the source photo of the bat wasn't actually
him standing next to Alvin Bragg, it's no
big deal.
Speaker 3: And this is a company that makes
baseball bats.
Then they put next to that picture a picture
of Alvin Bragg.
I didn't do it.
They did it to the I guess the people that
do the paper or somebody put pictures together.
But it was only in baseball, some.
Speaker 1: Pictures together.
Speaker 3: In order to promote made in or
wasn't on your post.
The truth sells.
No, no.
What they did is we posted the story, but
they had a picture up.
But they didn't put a picture up or the picture
was put up that nobody noticed or saw or the
nobody thought was bad.
These were two.
Speaker 1: Isn't this crystal clear.
Speaker 3: Pictures I was promoting Made in
America?
You make these baseball bats instead of sending
over to Japan and China and all of the places
where they're made.
This was a company, good company that makes
baseball bats and other things like that in
America.
They took that picture from the White House
and they put it up and then they put a picture
of Alvin Bragg up.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So, of course, we know nobody has alleged
that Trump was actually next to Alvin Bragg
holding a bat to his head.
The issue is Trump publicized the compilation
image of Trump holding a bat next to Alvin
Bragg.
Now, in this next clip clip, Trump's Trump
seems to say, Well, when we published it,
there was no picture.
And later the picture appeared.
Speaker 4: Let me be clear.
So you did not post the picture of you with
a baseball bat in the Oval Office next to
the picture with Bragg?
Somebody else did.
Speaker 3: I posted a very positive article,
you know, and whatever picture they put up,
they put up my people didn't put up the picture.
I think the picture maybe was either in the
article.
It was put in the article later.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So anyway, Trump posted it to Troth
Central and he seems very much confused about
how the Internet works.
Trump then talked about his rally over the
weekend, which we covered yesterday in Waco,
Texas.
Trump wildly claims that there were, in reality,
60,000 people there.
Now, there were 3500 people there.
But Trump says 60,000.
Speaker 3: Well, I deal with it.
We're dealing with very dishonest people.
We're dealing with thugs.
We're dealing with people who actually believe
that hate our country.
Right?
Last night, I had a rally with tens of thousands
of people.
The press admitted there were.
Speaker 1: So he says tens of tens of thousands.
Speaker 3: 25 or 30,000 people.
Speaker 1: The press admitted there were 25
or 30.
And then here's the whopper.
Speaker 3: Is you can double it, at least
in Texas, Waco, Texas.
Speaker 1: Right.
So the press admits there were 25 to 30000.
And so the real number is double, which is
60,000.
There were 3500 people there, maybe 5000.
That's it.
And this is a lie as old as Trump's political
career, you just make up numbers about the
number of people at your events.
And the truth, of course, is, like you and
I know that the number of people at an event
doesn't actually tell us much about how much
of the country supports Trump.
Trump might have had 3000 or 20,000 people.
It happened to be 3500, but imagine that he
had 20,000.
That still doesn't mean that he would win
an election or that he won in 2020 or whatever
the case may be.
But Trump and people around him see the number
of people at one rally as some kind of proxy
to his totality of support in a country of
340.
Trump then claimed that he would solve the
Russian invasion of Ukraine in a day, but
he definitely can't explain how because then
his enemies would know his plan for.
Speaker 3: One and World War two look like
pancakes.
Okay.
This is unbelievable because we have people
that don't know what they're doing.
But if it's not solved, I will have it solved
in 24 hours with Zelensky and with Putin.
Right.
And is a very easy negotiation to take place.
But I don't want to tell you what it is, because
then I can't use that negotiation and evil
work.
But it's a very easy negotiation to take place.
I will have it solve within one day, right?
Speaker 1: First day in office.
TRUMP What?
I mean, that's as realistic as he's going
to solve the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
in the first term.
He's going to build the Mexico wall where
Mexico will pay for it.
None of it's believable.
This is as unbelievable as anything else.
Then we get to what is, for some people, the
crux of this interview.
DeSantis and Trump really going after DeSantis.
And this is what a lot of Republicans didn't
like starts with HANNITY.
Just asking, I thought you guys were friends.
And Trump says, No, we were never friends.
Speaker 4: The question I'm asked the most
about about you of late is Ron DeSantis right?
This is the question.
What happened?
I thought they were friends.
Speaker 3: They're not friends.
I didn't know him well, but he was on impeachment.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So Trump says, and they cut this says, We
were not friends.
And I didn't really know the guy.
Then we really get into the meat of it.
And Trump again telling this story of when
Ron DeSantis came to Trump with tears in his
eyes.
And again, I continue to be shocked that the
number of grown men sobbing around Donald
Trump something about Trump makes big, tough
guys sob.
Speaker 3: So what happened with Iran is the
following clip came to see me.
He was getting killed.
He was being crushed.
Adam Putnam It was over.
I have many people that I know that worked
for Adam Putnam.
They said it was like a nuclear I hate to
use this expression, it was like a nuclear
weapon went off when you endorsed because
they considered the race to be over.
They had the race.
He had millions and millions of dollars and
he was way up in the polls.
He was beating Ron by 30 points or so.
It was over.
Ron came to see me tears in his eyes.
He said, I need you to do me a big favor.
Yeah.
First he is for the meeting.
Then he asked me for the favor.
Speaker 1: Crying.
Speaker 3: I said, What's the favor?
Would you endorse me?
I vote for you.
And but again, he.
A lot of people fought for me.
You fought for me only rightfully.
But you fought for me if you thought I was
right.
Right.
A lot more than he did.
But he said, I need your endorsement.
I said, Ron, you so far behind, I can't imagine.
Speaker 1: Does anyone believe this story.
Speaker 3: If you got George Washington's
endorsement combined with the great late,
great Abraham Lincoln, if you had their endorsements,
I don't think you could win, Ron, But tell
me about it.
Go ahead.
He said, I'm telling you, I think I could
win if I could get your endorsement.
And he was.
You'll have to check the records.
But many, many, many points.
It was over.
Yeah.
And the nomination just very close for nomination
was just okay.
I gave I said, let's give it a shot.
Okay.
You know, you defended me.
Adam Putnam didn't one way or the other.
I think he's probably a nice guy.
You know, I never met him until later.
A year later I met him.
He said when you did that, it was like a rocket
went up.
He said my race was over.
They were already buying furniture for the
for the governor's mansion.
They were going to win.
Speaker 1: All right.
So anyway, Trump saying DeSantis cried to
him.
And then that's and the rest is history.
And then lastly, Trump claiming that DeSantis
would be making pizza if it weren't for Trump.
Speaker 3: Then I had him get him.
I had to get him against the star of the Democrat
Party was going to be Stacey Abrams.
And now we call him a crackhead because that's
what he was a crack.
And then Gillum.
Gillum And there was no way Ron was going
to beat Gillum.
So he got the nomination, but there was no
way because this guy was going to be the future
of the Democrat Party.
And I said, Ron, you can beat this guy.
Let's go.
I got him.
The nomination, by the way.
Couldn't have never gotten the nomination.
He would be working in either a pizza place
or a law office right now.
Speaker 1: There you go.
He would be either in a pizza parlor or a
law office, which isn't that bad.
I mean, I think that those are two very different
careers, law, law, office or pizza parlor.
But needless to say, Trump is responsible,
deranged, visibly confused and disoriented.